Hi, and welcome to the Neil
Ashton Podcast.
In each episode, we explained
some of the fascinating ways
that science and engineering are
changing the world around us.
We talked to leading engineers
from elite level sports like
cycling and Formula One to some
of the world's top academics to
understand how fluid dynamics,
machine learning and supercomputing
are bringing in a new era of
discovery.
We also hear some of their life
stories, their career advice.
The lessons they've learned on
the way that I hope will be
helpful to you too.
So sit back and enjoy this
episode.
Hi, and welcome back to the Neil
Ashton Podcast.
Today's episode is one that is
focusing on a topic that I think
is interesting to so many people
and that is on supersonic
flight, supersonic travel.
I'm speaking to Peter Coen, who
is a legend within NASA
for all that he's done for
the supersonic program over the
past three decades.
And I wanted to speak to him
firstly because when I spoke to
some colleagues and
people I work with at NASA, they
all recommended I speak to
Peter as he is a fountain of
knowledge on this program.
We didn't really get into
actually a focus on him himself.
This was more of a topic on the
NASA program.
Although people tell me that he
is a private pilot and has some
amazing stories to tell.
But in, in this particular
episode, we focus more on the
actual NASA programs and what
they're doing.
And, and that is absolutely
fascinating.
We start the conversation going
back and looking at how, how did
we get to Concorde, you know,
that incredible aircraft that
was the first to go supersonic
for, you know, passenger travel.
And then talking, you know, why,
why did it stop?
What were the commercial reasons?
What were the technical reasons?
And then we transition into what
makes supersonic travel
difficult?
What are the engineering
challenges from a noise
perspective, from a regulatory
perspective, from an
aerodynamics perspective, and
going through step by step in
that process.
And, and for anybody here who is
an engineer, I think you'll find
that particularly interesting
talking about the specifics of
how they overcame some of the
issues with the sonic boom.
And then we start to go through
and talk about the specific Quesst
programme.
So this is NASA's project to
develop a prototype, the X-59
aircraft that is currently in
the process of being built.
That will be a test to
essentially validate all the
work that's been done and to
give data to the aviation
authorities to be able to set
the regulatory environment for
commercial entities to go and
build and hopefully release
these aircraft.
So we're at a really interesting
time.
This project has been going on
for quite a while and it feels
like we're getting very close
now to some very key tests that
will dictate this.
And we finish off with some
discussion around, of course,
hypersonic travel.
Of course, if you can do
supersonic, the logical question
is, couldn't you do hypersonic?
And then at the end, as I ask
most people on this podcast,
some sort of words of wisdom, I
guess, to people who are
aspiring aeronautics
professionals.
So this for me was personally
one of the really interesting
episodes.
I love the idea of supersonic
travel and Peter is such a great
communicator and it was an honour
to have him on the podcast.
So sit back and enjoy this
episode with Peter Coen on
supersonic travel.
So maybe we could begin.
I mean, this is, I think for
most people a fascinating topic.
But probably the one thing that
people think of when we talk
about supersonic travel is
Concorde.
So maybe as a bit of a starter,
could you, maybe, I know this is
difficult, summarize the history
of supersonic travel.
How did we get to the Concorde
program?
Sure.
It really is—it actually is a fascinating
history.
I mean, of course, in 1947, we had
the first supersonic flight, the
Bell X-1 out at what was then
Muroc or Edwards Air Force Base.
And you know, somebody heard of
sonic boom then maybe.
So that's a little interesting
history, but you know, from
there very rapid development of
supersonic military aircraft.
You know, in the US we had the
Century series fighters.
But you know, in in Britain it
was, they were, it was the
Lightning and other supersonic
aircraft.
And so supersonic flight became
pretty common pretty quickly in
the 1950s.
And, you know, pretty much as
soon as the basics were
understood, people started
thinking about, well, we should
have, you know, the next step
in, in supersonic travel, in
travel should be supersonic
travel.
So there were studies done
all over the world, really.
But, you know, of course, there
were English
studies too, and British
Aerospace began working on
designs and, you know,
eventually came to the, the
common program, the, the
English, you know, the British
French program to build the
Concorde.
So, you know, along that way,
along the way, as supersonic
flight became more popular, you
know, initially sonic booms were
kind of a novelty.
You know, they'd do them at air
shows and people would get all
excited about them.
But you know, as the
airplanes began to be used in training
more and more often, you started
having complaints of damage and,
you know, noise
complaints.
And you know when people, when
some people really started to
think about.
You know, regular supersonic
operations, I think they were
thinking of, we really were
thinking about, you know, the
entire air transportation market
would become supersonic and
people would begin to think
about the number of overflights
that that would involve.
The number of sonic boom
exposures that that people
would, you know, would hear
would become would become a
problem.
So.
It led to a number of studies.
Which involves community tests
of people's response to sonic
boom.
And most notably, there was a, a
very long test with many, many
exposures done in Oklahoma City
in the mid 1960s, but was
actually sponsored by the, by
the US FAA.
And, you know, it became quite
apparent that regular sonic boom
exposure would not be, would not
be, you know, you know, would
not be tolerable.
So as Concorde development
continued, you know, we also had
the US SST program and that's
really what drove a lot of the
the sonic boom testing in the US
was trying to understand the
impact of the US SST which
was going to be much bigger and
and potentially much louder in
terms of sonic boom than the
Concorde.
So eventually, you know,
Concorde did fly, but in, and I
think it was 1968, maybe 1969
was was first flight commercial
service started in 76.
But in between those two times
the FAA put in a ban on
supersonic flight over land.
They couldn't they there was
that idea that if you could
quiet the boom enough, you
could, you could fly over land
supersonic, but they didn't know
what how quiet it would need to
be.
So eventually they just said,
you know, no, no sonic, no, no
supersonic flight means no sonic
booms means nobody's going to
get annoyed.
So that, that was in 1973
that that ban was put in place
internationally.
There are other countries that
ban supersonic flight, but
pretty much everybody sticks to
what the International Civil
Aviation Organization agreed to was they
didn't put in a law, but they
or, or a standard, but they said
nobody should experience a, a
negative impact, an unacceptable
situation as they called it, due
to sonic boom noise.
So, you know, so by the mid
1970s we had, we had Concorde
operations on a very limited
scale and we had all the rules
put in place and that that, that
that continued into the
2000s when Concorde operations
ceased.
And but the research and, and
trying to understand how to
affect the sonic boom, how to
make it quieter.
And you know, that continued all
along through a number of
programs.
So was it the case that it was
almost a shock to the Concorde
developers to have this ban
because from what I guess it was
imposed after the aircraft had
essentially been designed, were
was the assumption that they
would be allowed to fly
anywhere?
And then when they put that ban
in, it was almost, yeah, too
late to really change the
fundamental design or
principles.
Yeah, there's a lot, There's a
lot to that actually.
You know, I think, I think
everybody kind, you know, in the
early development of supersonic
aircraft, you know, there was
kind of the there was very much
kind of this is in the US, but
as globally as well.
You know, people thought, you
know, technology advancement,
all technology advancement was
good and that in the 60s that
changed.
And sonic the, the advent of
sonic boom, you know, the
possibility of, of regular
exposure to sonic boom was a
part of that, that change.
So, you know, certainly the US
manufacturers and
British Aerospace and
Aérospatiale, you know, they,
they, they expected that they
would fly over land supersonic
and that the airplanes would be
used as.
As regular air transport so.
I don't know if it was a.
Shock, you know, but but I'm
sure they began to realize that
sentiment was building against,
you know, exposing people to
this new sound and it
definitely, you know, it
definitely hurt the market, you
know, for the aircraft.
I yeah, I suppose what I'm
getting to because my second
question was really why, Why did
Concorde ultimately stop and and
fail in some extent?
And I'm just wondering to that
point, was it an economic
reason?
Was it a technology reason?
And is there anything that is
essentially because they
couldn't fly over land, they
just destroyed the economic
model and what what caused
Concorde essentially to?
To, you know, not I've, I've
studied, I haven't really
studied the, the marketing of
it, but you know, there's a
couple of things.
You know, one of the things that
that NASA really believes and,
and kind of the supersonic
community believes that if
you're going to have regular
supersonic air transportation,
you have to the airlines have to
be able to operate the airplane
as they would any other
airplane.
So limiting it to just certain
over water routes limits the
market and limits the
effectiveness of the airplane.
So that was a definite strike
against, you know, Concorde.
It was, you know, it was a
marvel, you know, to, you know,
again, you know, essentially the
design was pretty much in place.
You know, a few years after the
first supersonic flight, you
had a supersonic airliner.
Fantastic.
But you know, so the technology
that was incorporated in it
it was was somewhat immature for
airliner technology.
And then we had, you know, we
had a couple of fuel crises and
then, you know, after the, after
the accident.
There was a, there was a
downturn, another economic
downturn, which you know, kind
of limited the operation.
So eventually, you know, being
able to continue an operation
with, with such such a small
number of aircraft serving such
a small market, I think you
know, the airlines,
basically, it was not
economically
viable for them to continue so.
There was regulation, there was
technology and there was
economics.
That all went into, I think, the
end of the the Concorde's
commercial operation.
Yeah, it is.
I've, I've been on Concorde, not
when it was flying, but in the
museum and I'm always amazed at
how small it is, how tight the
seats are compared now you know,
to, to to an aircraft how very
and obviously how expensive the,
the tickets were.
So it was, yeah, I guess as you
say it was, it was a novelty for
sure.
And I'm sure that helped for a
while.
But I guess it would be
interesting even if it didn't
stop for that reason.
Would, would there be the
pressure because of the I guess
now like first class travel is
so much about luxury and, and
the size of the cabins and all
this and you go into Concorde
and you're in this tiny little.
Seat well, that's an interesting
again, NASA does studies and
we're we're we talk to companies
that do studies and that that's
a factor.
But you know, you look at, you
know when given the opportunity
to get there sooner, most people
will choose sooner in in the
long run, so.
Yeah.
I from NASA's perspective,
we're, we're NASA's perspective,
you know, from the big picture
for NASA, we're trying to
innovate and do things that
improve air travel for, you
know, for the, for the traveling
public.
And so our mantra is kind of,
you know, yeah, getting there
faster, yeah, over long
distances is, is a marked
improvement in the experience of
the, the, the air traveler.
So, you know, that's if we can
do that in a way that is
affordable, sustainable, and,
you know, acceptable,
environmentally acceptable, then
if if we can put those
technologies in place, then you
know, there's a market there
that would definitely be of
interest to manufacturers.
I mean, it's for sure, I mean,
I, I travel quite a lot to the
US for conferences or for
meetings.
And there is no doubt that the
length of time it takes to
travel from Europe to the US, I
think does limit how closely
those countries can work
together.
Whereas I know that my US
colleagues who have to fly from,
let's say, California to
Washington, it's still a six
hour flight.
But anything I think less than five
or six hours is a different
psychological, different jet lag
different, just everything
compared to ten hours or, you
know, eight or ten hours.
So I can totally see why the
increasing business or or
closeness that I'm sure there's
economic benefits from making
air travel faster, you know,
promote people to maybe, yeah,
stay in touch more easily.
Yeah, that's, that's, you know,
again, that's kind of NASA's
part of NASA's vision is, you
know, it it, it makes a smaller
world if you can get there in in
half the time.
Yeah.
So what what the high level as
we go towards speaking about
the, you know, the NASA
programs, could you maybe just
explain to people the high level
factors that make supersonic
passenger jets technologically
challenging?
What is it about the nature of
supersonic travel?
A challenge from a noise point
of view, From a fuel efficiency
compared to transonic aircraft?
Well, I mean the the so yeah, so
we, we look at we look at as
there are barriers, you know,
that need to be overcome to make
supersonic travel, you know, as
I said, you know, economically
viable and and environmentally
acceptable.
So we kind of lumped them into
categories.
One of them is sonic boom.
You know, we have to be able to
fly over land without disturbing
people.
So we can talk a little bit more
about about how we do that.
But, you know, just right now.
So the airplane needs to be
shaped to to reduce the sound of
the sonic boom.
And that that's not a whole lot
different from, you know, the
what a supersonic, what Concorde
would look like.
But there are some things, you
know, to go faster obviously
requires more energy.
So, you know, there's no,
there's no getting around the
fact that it needs more fuel.
So but balancing, you know, the
fuel burn at high speed versus
the fuel burn at at low speed
and getting that that that
integrated design that.
Is efficient as possible, burns
as little fuel
as possible across the speed
regime.
That's, that's a key technology
challenge too. One of the things
that that, yeah, is, is maybe
people don't realize is, you
know, current subsonic air
airplanes have those great big
turbofan engines.
So they're accelerating a lot of
air, just a small amount to
create the thrust that they
need.
And that's, that's both
efficient and quiet at subsonic
speeds.
As you get to higher speeds, you
need your jet has to be faster,
you need to accelerate less air
more, you know to create the
thrust that you need to go
supersonic speed.
So you can't have a high bypass
turbofan.
So coming up with an engine
design that is again matches the
the requirements of low speed
and high speed, but also, for
take-off and
landing, can
effectively operate quietly so
with the lowest jet velocity you
know, the, the speed the, the
jet coming out of the tailpipe
as, as you can so that that
requires some unique engine
design emissions is a problem.
You know that the, the, the
Mach, the Mach number of the
airplane, the higher the Mach
number, the higher you fly.
Eventually you're, you're up in
the stratosphere where the
emissions of the engine can have
a magnified effect on, on the
ozone layer and the, you know,
the, the, the, the quality of
the atmosphere.
So paying attention to the, the,
how the fuel is burned in the
engine, the combustion process
and making a, a burner, a
combustor in the airplane that
creates as little
emissions as possible.
Is, is, is a major challenge for
supersonic aircraft.
If we go back into the 1990s
when there was the High-Speed
Research Program, emissions was
one of the big focuses.
Of that effort and the
technology that kind of found
its start in that program is now
in a lot of the engines that you
see on subsonic.
Airplanes.
So it's kind of come full
circle.
And now we're.
Looking at it again, can we, can
we improve it even more to get a
big, a bigger impact if we start
using those on the, on
supersonic aircraft again?
So there's that and there's
operations, you know, how do
you, you operate the airplane?
How do you mix the, the fleet
together so that supersonic
aircraft can fly as fast as it
can for as long as it can
without having an impact on
the subsonic
traffic.
So there's, there's a lot of,
there's a lot of technology
factors.
You know that that that that
need to be addressed airport
noise.
sonic boom and emissions are
kind of the three real barriers
to actually opening the market.
I think you know to to even a
supersonic business aircraft.
Well, I'm glad you mentioned
that because that was one of the
things I was to ask you about
from a, you know, conceptual
design point of view.
When you do the numbers and you
figure out the maths on, you
know, what's the, the best size
or how many passengers can you
put on this thing?
What do the, what do the sums
ultimately drive you to?
I, I'm guessing not a 300-person
aircraft like you would see now,
but much smaller.
So could you maybe talk about
how the aircraft design maths
work out in that point?
Of view so you know we're we're
doing the X-59 now we didn't
start out to do a demonstrator.
We we started out to in the in
the early 2000s, we had just
flown the Shaped Sonic Boom
Demonstrator and kind of proved
that this approach for quieting
sonic boom works in a real
atmosphere.
And there was a lot of kind of
innovative thinking going on
then about, you know, how we
would, you know, how, how we
could advance from where our our
state of knowledge on, on
quieting sonic boom to really
getting to something that
not only worked well, but was
what was practical in a design.
So we had some ideas.
We had new CFD, we had faster
computers, we had design systems
which enable us to do better
optimisation.
And we really thought we could
make a major change in the in
the loudness of the supersonic
aircraft.
So what we did is we worked with
NASA, worked with Boeing and
Lockheed in two separate studies
to say, OK, if we have this
technology and we incorporate it
in a future design, you know,
what, what, what's, what's
practical.
And what we wound up with was
about 100-passenger airplanes,
so something about the same size
as as Concorde that flies at
about Mach 1.8, two to three engines.
And, you know, 4,500 or so
miles range, so you know, trans-
Pacific, but but barely that all
kind of fit and enabled us to
make an airplane that met the
boom requirements, met the
landing and take-off noise
requirements and the emissions
requirements and was
much more efficient at cruise
than Concorde.
So the boom-shaping
technology, wanting
to meet the noise requirements and
trying to
make the airplane out of
materials that that don't have
to be, you know, we don't have
to use special materials for
high heat.
We have a propulsion
system that's balanced for take-off
or landing and supersonic
flight, say about Mach 1.8 is
the range that is the speed that
you want to go for.
So it's a little slower than
Concorde, but it's still twice
as fast as current subsonic
airliners.
And is that where still you
think the sweet spot is in terms
of the aircraft, the the most
practical aircraft, that's what
you started off with it is that
still the case that around 100
passengers, Mach 1.8, is that, is that
really what all the sort of
analysis studies converge to?
There have been more studies,
more market studies since then
and, and well, just recently
we've actually, you know, so
there's actually a kind of
another community of researchers
and, and companies that are
pushing for faster travel.
So Mach 4 or Mach 5.
And so NASA commissioned some,
some more recent studies that,
you know, since this is kind of
being driven by the high speed,
the higher speed community, we
set the Mach range at Mach 2 to
4.5.
You know what, what's the best
answer in that speed range?
Well, all the best designs came
out to be Mach 2.
You know, So what they're kind
of saying is, you know, and
they're, what we really were
seeing was those, those designs
were, were somewhat impractical
because they were constrained to
be Mach 2.
So we felt confident that, you
know, if we had stretched that
envelope down to Mach 1.7 or so,
we would have found even, you
know, we would kind of confirmed
our, our previous results.
So the answer is yes.
I think generally studies still
seem to point to that, yeah,
kind of given what we what we
know in, in, in terms of
technology and and given the the
challenges of higher speed
flight that for the first
products that that bring kind of
bring back supersonic flight
that 1.7–1.8 Mach range is, is
kind of the sweet spot.
OK.
And just to maybe, Oh no, please
go.
ahead. Well, take Boom.
You know, Boom Supersonic is is
trying to build essentially a
successor to Concorde smaller,
but you know, it's kind
of that same mission supersonic
overwater flight only they
started out, you know, talking
about Mach 2.4 and their current
design is Mach 1.7.
So.
That also kind of confirms where
where the technology will take
you.
Yeah.
And just maybe for people's
sense, is this actually let
let's maybe go through.
Could you just briefly introduce
the NASA program?
You know, there is a specific
NASA program with a certain name
And so could you maybe just
briefly introduce, you know,
what is that?
And the X-59 I know it there's
like a specific project, isn't
there?
Yes.
So again, after we, well, we,
we, we kind of, we proved this
technology to us at least.
So in, in our Boeing and
Lockheed studies, we, we did
designs, you know, conceptual
designs, we did a lot of CFD
analysis and then eventually we
tested those designs in wind
tunnels.
So small scale models, really
trying to test what we did.
We did a number of tests, but
the focus of the test was, did
we get the quiet boom design
right?
And we, and lo and behold, we,
our CFD predictions matched our
experiment
almost perfectly.
So we knew that technology could
work.
And so there was, there was a
lot of excitement about taking
the next step.
Well, let's, let's try and fly
it.
But you know, we were very
confident in the CFD.
So, you know, we weren't going
to actually prove the technology
in flight.
We, you know, we could
demonstrate it in flight, but
you know, what we learned from
flight would be, you know, how
robust is it?
You know, does it change in
different weather conditions?
You know, what speed ranges work
best?
You know, kind of that
information like that, which
was, you know, exciting science
to do, but was not.
A.
Program that was getting much
traction with, with, with NASA
or with, you know, our, our, our
budget people in the, in the
government.
In parallel to all this work, we
were doing research on how
people respond to the sound from
supersonic aircraft.
So we had done laboratory
studies where we built these
simulators which essentially
create a sonic boom or a quiet
sonic thump, you know, in a lab
situation.
We had, we had found that, you
know, the numbers that we were
getting in our designs, we were
able to get to in our designs
were kind of at the threshold
where people really stopped,
almost stopped noticing the
sound.
So what, what, what really sold
us was we really wanted to
understand how, how people in a
community, you know, going about
their daily lives would respond
to the sound, what level, what
sound level would be acceptable.
And that's where we got the, the
traction.
So that's what became the Quesst
mission.
That's the current big NASA
activity.
So what we're doing is, and the
best way to generate that sound
in a community is to use an
aircraft that creates a
representative sound.
So the Quesst mission kind of has
three phases.
The first phase, well, all
phases are active now.
The focus right now is building
the X-59 aircraft.
It's a unique.
Technology.
It's a demonstrator aircraft.
It's a research aircraft.
It's not a prototype for, for a
supersonic airliner, but it does
create a sound that's similar to
what we think the sounds of the
future supersonic aircraft will
be.
So we're designing that
airplane.
We've, we've contracted with
Lockheed Martin to build the
airplane for us.
Their contract runs through
getting the airplane in the air,
doing all the envelope
expansion, as we call it, you
know, the safety of flight
checks.
And then they'll essentially
hand us the keys and the
airplane will become NASA's
property in the second phase of
the of the effort.
We're going to take that
airplane, we're going to try,
we'll make sure that the sound
that we're getting is what we
expected.
So we call that acoustic
validation.
Is it loud enough?
Can we vary it enough?
You know, is it affected by
the atmosphere?
Things like that.
We really want to understand
that sound that we make because
eventually we want people to
hear that sound.
And that's phase three.
So phase three, we'll take the X-
59 and we'll go to different
communities.
Right now that we've got five or six
tests planned.
It's something in different
places in the United States.
We haven't picked those places
yet, but we're we're, we're
narrowing it down if you wish.
But so the idea is to is to
expose a community to the sounds
of quiet supersonic flight at
different noise levels, have
surveys, have microphones in the
community to measure the sound,
have people taking surveys to see
how they respond to the sound.
So we can create a dataset
that describes how you know
what, at what sound level it is,
is the sound acceptable and what
sound level is it annoying.
In parallel to that, we're
working with the International
Civil Aviation Organization,
particularly their Committee on
Aviation Environmental
Protection, because those are
the people that write the rules
for noise from, from aircraft.
The current regulations for take-
off and landing noise all come
from ICAO.
They're implemented by, you
know, in the UK it's CAA and the
US it's FAA.
But ICAO, all those groups
participate in ICAO.
They set the standard.
So the Quesst mission, the main
goal of the Quesst mission is to
give ICAO the data that they can
use to set the limit of sound
for future supersonic aircraft.
So to to create that standard
that that manufacturers could
then design airplanes to.
OK, I I see that's, that's
really interesting.
So what you're basically saying
is, you know, they have to be
conservative in nature when it
comes to rules, the rules today
that they need, they need as
realistic data as possible to
make an informed decision.
And So what your project will do
is help set the foundations,
which I then guess when
commercial companies like Boom
or others want to certify their
aircraft, they will be
certifying to those noise levels
and I guess a certain distance
away and a certain height.
And it's all the parameters I
guess of how they measure.
So the standard
has, you know, kind of
three elements.
It's a metric.
So what are you going to
measure?
What, what, what, what, what's
the best way of measuring the,
the, the people's response?
What, what number?
What process? There's a procedure.
You know, so everybody who
applies for a type certificate,
you know, has to go through the
same procedure.
So it's consistent and then
there's a limit, you know what,
what's the value of the metric
that that you can choose.
So the Quesst mission really
helps to inform all three of
those elements.
You know, we'll be getting a lot
of data.
So we we've got some candidate
metrics, you know, we'll be able
to test which metric works best
when we're doing that acoustic
validation phase that's kind of
that kind of mimics what the
certification process would look
like.
So we'll get it.
We'll be getting data that can
help define that
certification process.
And then when we do the
community testing, we'll be
actually getting the data that
will help support defining the
limit.
You know, because NASA, NASA can
give, you know, we've got a good
reputation as being honest
scientific, an honest scientific
community.
We can give that data.
We're, you know, we're pulling
in as much of the international
community as we can so that they
understand what we're doing.
But, you know, it's, it's
essentially creating that data.
But then again, it's up to ICAO
and and the international
community to define what the the
actual limits and the actual
procedure are going to be.
So I'm sure the most difficult
question is the timeline of of
this.
So when is the when is the
aircraft expected to be handed
over to you from Lockheed to be
able to start doing some of that
validation?
Yes, yeah.
So yeah, we've, we've
experienced delays, very
exciting though we just had our
first engine runs.
So we've started the engine on
the airplane for the first time.
So that's kind of a a big step
forward in, in kind of the last
phase before we fly.
We have, we have to do all this,
this really integrated testing
where we're essentially the
airplane is completely alive and
we're running all the systems
and, and making sure
everything's talking to each
other.
So once we got that done, then
we, you know, of course you, you
do taxi tests first and you drive
around, you know, gradually
increasing speed and then you
have first flight.
So originally we had planned to
hopefully do first flight this
year, but we've had some delays
in getting, getting to the point
where we could do the, the
engine run.
So now we're looking at sometime
next year for first flight the
phase one, this envelope
expansion phase is planned for
about a year.
So, you know, things go well
sometime early in 2026, maybe
we'll get the we'll get the keys
to the airplane and.
We'll be able to start our start
our acoustic, you know, our
acoustic testing.
So would it be fair to say that,
you know, realistically assuming
various factors, 2030 could be
when the international community
would have, could set new rules,
they've done all the tests,
you've given them all the data,
they've debated it and they've
set and written these new rules.
Is that approximately or you
think it?
Could be faster than that.
It's interesting: CAEP is the
Committee on Aviation Environmental
Protection, they, they have a
three-year cycle.
So they have a meeting and at
the meeting all the decisions
based on the work that's gone on
in the previous three years are
are finalized and accepted and
then given to the ICAO Council
for final approval.
So actually the the 13th CAEP
cycle is just coming to an end
now.
So in February of 2025 will be
the CAEP/13 meeting.
So. 2028 is the next one, 2031
is CAEP/15 and that is our
target for, well that is that is
ICAO's target now for bringing
the standard forward to the
council for approval.
So we are on a timeline to
deliver that data.
To give in, in, in, in in a
timely enough manner, to give
them plenty of time to review
it, debate it.
And then finish writing the
standard to bring forward at the
CAEP/15 meeting in 2031.
OK, Yeah.
So maybe before we go any
further, I guess we should
actually talk about what
visually is probably the most
distinguishing feature the the
sort of long nose, which if I
understand correctly was one of
the technologies that has been
able to reduce the the sonic
boom.
Could you maybe talk a little
bit about the physics and how
this helps to reduce the the
noise?
Yeah, sure.
Yeah.
So, you know, of course, sonic
boom is the result of of shock
waves.
Shock waves are instantaneous
pressure changes that occur when
an aircraft is flying faster
than the speed of sound.
Essentially, You know, for
normal aircraft, the subsonic
aircraft, it's creating a
pressure change and essentially.
That's being communicated in
front of the airplane because.
Pressure changes like a sound
it, it all travels at the speed
of sound, so that that's racing
out in front of the airplane and
kind of the air is starting to
get out of the way.
Well, if you're going faster
than sound, you know the air
doesn't know the plane is coming
essentially.
So you get.
An.
Instantaneous pressure change
called a shock wave.
Whether it's created by an
airplane or a rifle bullet, it
doesn't matter.
It's it's anything faster than
sound creates an instantaneous
pressure change.
If you look at an airplane,
anytime the flow is going over,
it has to make a turn.
As it goes over some part of the
airplane, you create a
shock wave.
So there's a shock wave on the
nose near the airplane.
There's a shock wave on the nose;
there's one on the canopy, the engine
inlets.
Anything that sticks out from
the airplane creates a
shock wave.
So if you can visualize those
shock waves, which we can do,
we've developed some really
interesting technology.
Because we've been able
to do it in the wind tunnel for
a while, but now we can do it in
flight.
You can actually see through
what's called schlieren imaging.
You can see the shock waves.
And if you can
see them, what you see
is they're all different
strengths and they're all kind
of randomly spaced along the
airplane wherever the components
are because of that, because the
shock waves, the different
strengths as that signal.
And again, that signal travels
out in three dimensions.
Some of it travels towards the
ground and that's what we're
most interested in.
But as it's as that signal is
traveling, because those waves
of different strength, they're
actually starting to pile up on
each other.
So in a short distance from the
airplane, all those shock waves
have piled up into two: one, you
know, nose shock—what becomes
called the nose shock, the first
leading one and then the tail
shock.
And that's a very stable
acoustic system.
Travels to the ground, it's
getting attenuated, it's getting
weaker and weaker as it reaches
as as it goes towards the
ground.
But still when it reaches the
ground, you hear two very rapid
pressure changes which you hear
as bang-bang.
You know of, of, of a sonic
boom.
So what we found is the best
approach, the the approach that
seems to work and and can be
integrated into a practical
airplane is to keep those shock
waves from merging.
So the whole shape of the X-59
that long nose is, is it's all
designed to create a system of
shock waves near the
airplane where the shocks are
relatively the same strength and
relatively evenly spaced along
along the length of the
airplane.
So this the initial system has
all these shock waves in it.
And because they're, they're
similar in strength, they don't
merge as the signal travels to
the ground.
They just get the each, each
individual shock gets
attenuated.
And that's actually more of a
benefit because you get down
into the denser atmosphere, the
shocks start to get smeared a
little bit more.
So by the time you get to the
ground, you're left with kind of
this gradual pressure rise instead
of instead of the sharp pressure
increase.
So you hear a thump or, or a
thud-thud instead of that, that
very disturbing bang-bang.
So if you look at the the X-59,
it has a lot of features that we
learned about when we did those
airliner studies that long.
The long slender nose sets up
most of the forward part of of
the acoustic signature if you
wish.
And then at the back end it
becomes much more complicated.
So you're really trying to
manage the shocks and there's a
little bit more than just having
them be the same
strength.
You can kind of get them to
cancel each other a little bit.
So integrating the engine, so
it's like the engine on the X-
59, it's mounted on top of the
aircraft.
So to prevent the shock wave from
the engine inlet from kind of
impinging on the
bottom signature, the signature
that travels to the ground, the
the tail of the airplane is kind
of unique on the X-59.
We've got a little canard, we've
got a conventional horizontal
tail and then a little T-tail.
Each of those features helps us
generate the lift we need and
helps us trim the airplane, but
minimizes the impact of those
features on the on the sonic
boom.
They just look nice as well.
I have to say the aircraft
actually looks quite nice, which
always helps, right I.
Think yeah, exactly right.
Well, this is an adage in
aircraft design that if it looks
good, it is good.
Yeah, of course, Concorde
famously had to, you know, tweak
the nose for visibility.
How about on on this type of
design, what what's the
visibility?
And for the pilots, what's their
opinion?
It's bad.
We, we, we have, we have a new
approach that's it's and thank
you for asking the question
because it's really one of the
one of the unique features that
NASA has contributed to the
design of the X-59 is our
external vision system.
So rather than having a forward
facing window, we have a camera
that sticks out from the, from
the nose. It's mounted on
the forward fuselage and it
creates a high-definition visual image
for
the pilot that's displayed on a
screen in front
of his seat.
It's a really interesting
technology.
We've, we've, we've flown it in
kind of demonstration flights on
subsonic airplanes.
And we found that it gives the,
the cameras and the screens have
reached the point where they can
give the pilot the same visual
acuity as they would have with
normal, with their eyesight,
their eyes looking through the,
looking through the window.
We did a study where there was a
pilot, you know, flying the
airplane and then there was a
pilot in the, in the back
looking at the screen.
And we flew against opposing
traffic.
And it turned out that the pilot
in the back could actually, you
know, would generally pick out
the targets faster or earlier
further away than the pilot in
the front.
But that's not the end of it.
I mean, if you've got this
screen in front of you, you can
mix the radar, infrared, you
know, other sensor features in
to really improve situational
awareness.
You know, for people who fly,
you might not see an airplane,
but when when air traffic
controller says, you know,
you've got traffic, twelve o'clock, two
miles and you look in that
direction.
Your chances of.
Seeing it are much better than
if you just kind of, you know,
generally looking well, just
imagine if if instead of the
controller saying it, you know,
the radar system put a little
circle on your screen and said,
hey, there's an airplane out
here.
You, you, you would always be
able to, to, to see the traffic.
So it's a unique technology.
It enables the supersonic
aircraft to be designed without
having a complicated heavy nose
drooping system.
But it's also something that you
know could have applications in
other in other types of aircraft
as well.
How much?
How much is the pilot or the
flying experience influencing
the design?
You know, if you're a car, if
you were, if you're designing a
car, you actually think about
driver comfort.
You think about how easy it is
to drive the car, to look out
the window to the experience.
I I always got the impression
that planes were designed almost
without any consideration for
the pilot, but I guess that's
maybe not true.
I'm just wondering for this how
much you factor in the pilot's
feedback and their needs.
So, you know, human factors is a
big part of aircraft design now.
And I think, you know, maybe,
you know, when the first
airplanes came out, there was
less attention to, you know,
just give them the instruments.
But now I think that's a big
part of, you know, how do you
design the, the, the aircraft
instrument panel?
How do you display information
so the pilot can make maximum
use of it?
You know, in a safe
manner?
You know, one, one thing unique
about the X-59 is it's, it's
an X-plane.
So you know, with the X-plane
approach, the idea is we have.
We have certain key things that
we want to demonstrate and for
an X-plane you really want to
make that as small a set of
things as as possible.
So for us, it's.
It's all about, it's all about
the sonic boom.
So, you know, besides the shape
of the airplane, the airplane is
kind of a.
You know, a
mishmash of parts from
other airplanes here.
We've got F-16 landing gear,
we've got an engine from an F-18,
etcetera.
So the X-plane you know, just
try and make it work.
So we did not spend a lot of a
lot of energy on, on human
factors, but we did, you know,
look at it.
So we got our pilots involved
early.
On, you know, we knew, you know,
we wouldn't have the screen, but
you know, we knew kind of beyond
that kind of wanted to look
pretty much like a, a modern
fighter aircraft inside as a
single-seat airplane.
But you know, the pilots got in.
We have a, we have a really very
sophisticated, we have actually
have two, one at Lockheed, one
at NASA, really very
sophisticated simulators.
So that we put them in the
simulators, you know, with,
with, with, you know, the
cockpit design in there and they
were able to interact with it,
give feedback and then, you
know, the, the design was
updated.
Yeah, as, as we went along.
So it's it's, it's it's it's
it's.
It's not a huge factor for the X-
59.
It's a big factor for, you know,
actual commercial aircraft.
So I was actually wondering as
maybe a bit of a tangent,
there's obviously a lot of
discussion about computational
fluid dynamics reducing the
reliance of wind tunnel
technology.
You know, if you can do more in
CFD and I believe for this
program, CFD was a big factor
in being able to, you know,
iterate quickly and, and
visually see what what was going
on.
But I was actually wondering,
you mentioned about simulators
because obviously normally
there's wind tunnel to CFD, but
then you have to do a flight
test, you know, you actually
need to go out and do it.
How much have simulator
technology advanced that you can
model some of the sort of flight
test behaviour through a
simulator?
Is that getting also more and
more accurate?
Much, much
more sophisticated, yeah.
And, you know, again, for X-59,
it's, it's, it's, it's, you
know, it's a unique airplane
that, you know, the design will
create some interesting, you
know, some, some flight
characteristics that are not
typical of, of, of fighters or,
or transports.
So we really wanted to
understand how, you know, how,
how those things worked and, and
how the pilot would interact
with them.
So getting a simulation.
So there's, there's so much
simulation that goes on now.
There's, there's simulation
without the pilot, there's
simulation with the pilot,
there's simulation without
hardware, you know, like, like
the control actuator and the
simulation with hardware.
So, you know, the whole
simulation process is, is a huge
part of the, the aircraft design
process right now.
So you know, like for X-59, we,
we did a lot of analysis, we did
do some wind tunnel testing.
You know, there's still, there's
still design, there's still
points in the flight envelope
where the CFD is not all that
great.
So you like to augment your CFD
analysis with with testing, but
you know, compared to previous
designs, we didn't do a lot of
wind tunnel testing.
As a matter of fact, we
finalized the low boom design,
the boom, you know, quiet-boom
design of the X-59 without doing
wind tunnel testing of the
geometry.
So, you know, that's how far the
CFD has come.
We put all this stuff in the in
the in the simulator.
You know, it's been iterated on
a few times.
So, you know, we're, we're,
we're, we're going into flight
test with a very good idea of
what, what the pilot will
experience flying the airplane
throughout the flight envelope.
Yeah, it's, it is amazing how
the technology is sort of, yeah,
moved on from that point of
view.
Just maybe I'm trying to think
of a few questions, more
practical questions.
So the noise, as you say, going
over, the idea is it's a sort
of soft thump, which is less.
It's something like, you know,
we're used to everyday sounds like,
you know, I guess drones—just
distant thunder or, you know,
somebody's car door closing.
And we compare the the sound to
to sounds like that.
But what about take-off and landing?
I mean the, you know, you can
go on YouTube now and look at
Concorde taking off and you
know, it was an absolute racket,
smoke billowing out of the
engines.
You know, like a real difference
to, like a normal aircraft.
What's the—not for the
X-59 now?
But I mean more just for like
theoretical design concepts.
How much is the the engine
noise?
Because it's, as you say, it's
not a conventional engine.
How much is that different or
limiting factor?
It's, it's again, we talked
about it earlier.
It's another kind of
barrier technology that you know
that we, we made a lot of
advances in. Again, it's
not on the X-59.
We're just using an existing
engine, but as part of the, the
bigger technology program in, in
NASA aeronautics, called the
Commercial Supersonic Technology
Project.
Airport noise is, is one of our,
one of our, our big efforts.
So, you know, we're looking at
the, the, the engine cycle, you
know, so we can't have a super
high bypass engine, but at Mach
1.7 we can have some higher, we
can have much higher bypass, you
know, much more fan component
than the Concorde did.
So that's that's a major help.
Our jet that you know, the jet
coming out of the back of the
engine at subsonic at take-off
is actually subsonic.
It's not like Concorde, where the
jet was coming out faster
than the speed of sound, which
creates noise, you know, of its
own.
So our jet is subsonic.
We've got nozzle technologies
which mix faster flow with
slower flow.
So the aggregate result coming
out the back end is slower.
And there's a whole idea of, you
know, the propulsion
installation.
Can you use that to, to help
reduce noise?
So all of those things are being
studied and you know, we, we
think again, we've, we've just,
we've done testing, but we think
we've got a solution that can
make supersonic
aircraft as quiet as the current
limits for noise for subsonic
aircraft.
So that's a, that's a big
improvement relative to where
Concorde was.
So I guess the, the big question
on most people's minds is what,
what do you think is the
likelihood of a commercial
version of this?
What is the, there's obviously
the research going on you're
doing, there's companies like
Boom, but from what I could
gather, Boom, that design looked
more like a traditional or more
traditional design than than,
than what you have, I mean.
Yeah.
So, so Boom's approach is
kind of unique.
They, they want it.
They, they, they, they, they,
you know, they see that there's
a market now that they would
like to capitalise.
They've talked about their next
generation of airplane
incorporating, you know, boom
shaping again.
They, they don't want to commit
to doing a design for a low boom
aircraft without having a
standard in place.
As a matter of fact, if they
don't want to commit really to,
well, they're kind of committed,
but they're
working with ICAO and the FAA is
working with ICAO to put a noise
rule in place for supersonic aircraft—a
landing-and-take-off
noise rule in place for
supersonic aircraft.
So that would give them that
certainty.
The work, the work with ICAO
really started because there was
a group of companies that really
felt that they could
bring a supersonic business jet
product, business aircraft
product to market if they had a
regulation on how loud
it needed to be when it flew
over land or how quiet it needed
to be when it flew over land.
So there's, there's definitely
that market out there in the
near term for a smaller
aircraft.
NASA is still bullish: if
we continue down this path, there
are technology solutions out
there which could make it
possible to, to design an
airliner that could, you know,
serve a supersonic market.
So what's what's stopping it?
So let's imagine the rules come
out and they are essentially
aligned to what you already know
from your simulations.
I, you know, because I presume
you already have a, an estimate
and all the flight test is
doing really is proving it out.
I guess you know, you have
analytical methods.
So let's just assume that they
agree with your numbers.
Is it is the technology ready?
Is it a case that, you know, a
Bombardier, a Boeing, or whoever
the company is can just
basically do it?
I know, I know.
I'm massively oversimplifying
things here.
Or is there still something
missing?
So I, I think that that for a,
for a smaller aircraft, a
business type aircraft, the
technology is very close.
The key challenge really
for a near term product is the
engine, because you need, you
need something that, that gives
you the efficiency that you need.
but will meet that, that
new landing and take-off noise
rule.
It's possible you could do it
with a, with a modification to
an existing engine, change the,
change the front end, change the
back end.
But more than likely you're
going to need a, a new engine.
And that's
magnified a little bit more for
the larger product.
You really need kind of a, a, a
bigger step in technology, in
engine technology to be able
to make the airplane meet noise
and emissions limits.
And by big and small are you
talking small being the hundred
person?
No, I'm talking small being
yeah, the next step for
Gulfstream say, yeah, an
airplane that's, you know, room
for maybe eight or ten passengers or
maybe up to 50,
like Boom was imagining—or 40.
I can't remember exactly where
their target is, but so that's
the smaller airplane.
What we're thinking
about for the first generation
of you know, airliner products
would be around a
100-seat airplane.
OK.
So what I understand you're
saying that it's, it's the
engine technology in some ways
that is the the more challenging
technology and it obviously gets
a more important or challenging,
the bigger, the heavier that it
becomes.
Think of it as: a business jet can
afford to be a little
less efficient because there's
people willing to pay for speed.
But the airliner needs
efficiency, quiet and low
emissions, which
takes a new set of technologies.
There are ideas
out there; there are technologies
at kind of the infancy
level, but they
need to mature.
And is there any, you know, how
the economics work when when
something aligns to something
else, there's double the reason
to do it?
Is there any similar reason,
like a military reason or
another reason that aligns this?
Or is this quite unique in some
ways for a passenger supersonic?
The military is not
really interested in quiet.
They would love
to have supersonic speeds.
They don't, It doesn't seem to
be a major requirement for
military missions, you know, at
the moment, because if you look
what's out there now, the
airplanes can go supersonic, but
not very supersonic.
They certainly don't
cruise supersonic.
Yeah, if they could do it, would
they?
Yeah, maybe.
But yeah, they obviously, you
know, other tech, other
requirements, you know, stealth
and IR are kind of driving
military designs, which you
know, the intersection between
that and low boom design is
not there.
So, so it really is, would you
say companies are just hedging
their bets or waiting because
they're just they're just not
sure when the rules will change.
So it's almost hard for them to
put the investment in to start
designing something if they're
unclear? Is that also one of the
key barriers to it?
Yeah, it comes and goes.
I mean, there was, there was,
there was a lot of work going on
a few years ago.
Some of the companies have, have
put those efforts on the back
burner.
Essentially.
I, I, I would say yes, they're
waiting for those regulatory
guidance, you know, that, that,
that, you know, understanding of
what, of what, what their design
requirements will need to be
before they, before they plunge
back into looking
at products.
So maybe, and again, this is
always a common question, I must
admit I'm guilty of sometimes
thinking the same.
And you, you partially answered
it before, but maybe we could be
more explicit if let's say the
supersonic 1.8 Mach number is
solved.
So, you know, the new rules come
out, there is sufficient
economic reason for the for the
engine manufacturers to do it.
And a supersonic business jet
comes out.
In your mind, what's the
technical or economic potential
of a hypersonic passenger
travel?
OK, not 100 people, but you
know, 20–30 people.
Mach 5, Mach 6. Is that science
fiction?
Is it?
Is it possible?
I wouldn't, I wouldn't put
it in terms of science fiction,
but the you know, the challenges
are are are much, much greater
than for for supersonic.
You get to you get to very high
altitudes and you get to very
high temperatures when you get
to Mach 4 and Mach 5.
So, you know, being able to
design something that's
reusable, you know that the
materials that will last for,
you know, for thousands of
flights.
And then so there, you know,
then some of the safety
considerations, you know, one of
the things that airplanes are
designed for the event of a
depressurization, you know, the,
the, you know, there's a way to
keep people, you know, keep
people alive until the
airplane gets down.
When you're up at
70,000–80,000 feet, that's a
huge, huge challenge.
So yeah, I know NASA is NASA is,
we have a hypersonics project.
They're looking at hypersonics
technology more from the the
point of view of, you know what,
what would it be for helping
space launch?
You know, what would its
applications be in space launch?
But again, we had this whole
study looking at, you know, is,
is high speed flight a
possibility?
Peter's opinion is it's going to
be a very long time before the
technology is ready to even even
take, you know, eight or ten people
into hypersonic
flight.
Who knows?
Maybe, you
know, the whole idea of orbital
transport, you know, will come
before hypersonic flight
because, again, you know,
getting, getting people on board
and making it safe and
economical is a, is a, is a big
step.
Yeah, I think the overriding
thing for most people is, and
I'm sure you feel the same being
so passionately involved in this
project.
There's always, normally we're
used to technology adoption
being a linear thing.
You know, something gets faster,
faster, faster.
And we almost never go
backwards, do we?
You know, the internet's got
faster, computers have got
faster.
It's always a sort of
peculiarity that we did go
supersonic and we were doing it
and now we've sort of gone
backwards.
And I always, I guess that's why
for most people, supersonic
travel is such an intriguing
thing because they know it used
to be.
And I guess some people
were lucky enough to fly in
Concorde and maybe they even
more so wish it were still here.
But for people like me, it's,
it's just a fascinating thing
that we did it and now, you
know, I guess it's like going to
the moon.
You know, we, we did it, but we
haven't been back for quite a
while.
And but I guess that's also
changing but.
You know.
It's it's.
Yeah.
I mean, you know, spaceflight
did the same thing.
It was, you know, it was we
needed that.
We needed that technology.
There was a space, there was a
space race.
So, you know, it was a stretch.
You know, the moon, the moon
landing was a was a big stretch.
Concorde was a big stretch.
And you know, maybe we stretched
a little too far, you know,
proved that it was practical.
But supersonic flight, for
example, revealed that there
were some, some things which,
you know, which you have to, you
have to create a balance.
You know, we like to go faster,
but we can't disturb people's
lives.
You know, now we've got
aircraft.
Aircraft are going to have to be
sustainable.
They have to, you know, not, not
contribute to, to, to climate
change.
So there's more things to weigh
than just speed, which,
you know, again, kind of puts
barriers in the way of, of, of
reaching that goal. One quick
question before I maybe
completely change topic: battery
technology, it's always been I
remember for cars, there was a
point when people said it was
never going to be available for
cars electric, you know, they
have a little golf buggy and
that's about it.
There's no way it's ever going
to be for a car.
And yet suddenly the whole
market started to transform and
it really felt like there was a
step change in the adoption of
electric.
I haven't been following it as
closely, but where do you see
battery?
Battery technology for aircraft
propulsion?
I don't mean complete electric
aircraft. I'm not a battery guy.
But I
will say that, you know, in in
NASA aeronautics, unique new
sustainable propulsion systems
are, you know, are are, are an
area of intense interest.
So we have a number of efforts
looking at yeah, battery-powered
electric flight for smaller
aircraft.
We have something called the
Electrified Powertrain Flight
Demonstration.
It's an effort that's going on
right now.
There's two contractors,
GE and magniX. magniX has built
a number of electric-powered
airplanes already, investigating,
you know, what it would take to
get there.
Would it would it be battery?
Would it be hybrid?
Would it use fuel cells?
You know, all all those kind of
features towards, you know,
making essentially non-
combustion propulsion a viable
option.
There's there's a lot of work
that needs to be done.
But again, you know, like you
said, I mean, when people, you
know, a few years ago, people
couldn't imagine an electric
car, people couldn't imagine a a
rocket that would come back and
land
on the ground.
So, so you know, never say, you
know, it's you try to challenge
yourself, you know, to be
realistic and think about what
you know we can do in the near
term, but you really should
never say never.
Yeah, exactly.
Yeah, being caught by some
scissors that probably wasn't on
people's minds a while ago.
So maybe the maybe the final
question for you, which is
you've worked for NASA for
decades now, I guess, you know,
maybe more than 30 years.
What advice would you give to
people who are looking to start
a career in aeronautics?
But I know it's probably a
question you get a lot, but what
would your advice be if you, if
you're somebody maybe in the
final years of school, thinking
about university, thinking about
career, what would be your
advice?
Well, I mean, one of
the things I always tell people
I know I got a degree in
aerospace, aeronautical
engineering, which you know,
gave me a unique set of skills,
obviously, you know which got me
into the aerospace business.
There are other degrees, you
know, which you should, you
know, electrical engineering,
you know, mechanical
engineering, all, you know, all
of those things can give you an
opportunity to get into an
aerospace field.
You know, for people in school,
you know, there's, there's so
many internship opportunities.
I, I, you know, I say, you know,
take any, any opportunity that
you have to do that, you know,
take it because it, you know,
gives you experience to, to help
you, you figure out what you
really want to do.
It gives you exposure to how
industry works and you meet
people, you know, who could,
you know, be a
benefit to you when you start
your career.
You know, beyond that, when you
get to work, be a team player.
Be willing to do something that
puts yourself outside of your
comfort zone.
I was, you know, pretty much a
technology guy, you know, very
happy doing my little aircraft
design work.
My bosses kept pushing me to get
involved in more of these
multidisciplinary studies that
were going on.
And then, you know, it
was a challenge for me, you
know, to get out there and
interact with people.
But,
you know, it
definitely gave me a skill set
which was, you know, really very
important as I got into the
position where I helped create
the
program that eventually led to
creation of the Quesst mission.
So, you know, by being able to
work with people and, and, you
know, set common goals and, you
know, set up an environment
where you can achieve those
goals that, that was all part
of the background.
You know, exposing
myself to, to just to things
outside of, you know, just the,
the typical math and science
helped me, you know, helped
set me on that path.
And is there any in in now, I
guess as the aerospace industry
is changing and the startups
around and you know, do you
think how valuable is it for
people to, for example, do a PhD
and go down the more academic
becoming an expert or how much
of it is valuable to also gain
sort of industrial experience?
You know, would you, if you're
looking at employing somebody,
would you, would you like
somebody who's, you know, worked
at different smaller aircraft
manufacturers or companies and
bring diverse skills?
Or would you tend to say to
people, no, go down the more
academic you know, doing a PhD
or maybe becoming a research
scientist?
Is there anything
you've observed? There's, there's
benefits to, to everything.
Again, I, I talked about being,
being able to work as part of a
team, you know, so to me, if I'm
hiring people, someone who's had
that kind of experience would
be someone
that I would look for, you know,
to bring forward.
You know, that said, you know,
we've got, we've got people, you
know, that have come to NASA
from, from, you know, from
different higher education, you
know, from PhDs, from, from
master's programs.
And yeah, they're, they're just,
they're, they're brilliant, you
know, so that puts them on the
right path to begin with.
They've kind of honed that
knowledge.
They've already maybe, you know,
got this idea that they can do
something new and unique.
And you, you put them with a
team that addresses all the
other aspects of that, that new
and unique idea. And
that's how you get to
breakthroughs.
And that's kind of, that's a lot
of what happened with the
design that, you know, the
design that led us to
X-59.
Well, thank you so much for
taking the time to speak.
I mean, what I think I'll do is
I'll put a bunch of links for
people to follow because I know
there's lots of, you know,
videos and, and, and papers that
have been published on these
things that maybe people could
dive into.
And of course, you know, the
NASA website,
nasa.gov/quesst—two s's—
there's all kinds of information
about the, the project there.
People can sign up for our
boarding pass, where, you
know, your name will be
digitally carried aloft on the
first flight of the X-59.
And, you know, again, it's a
great way to interact with,
you know, get information
about what's going on at NASA.
Great well, I, I certainly hope
that I'll have the
opportunity to fly on a
supersonic aircraft and I, I,
I'm sure that if it does happen
it will most likely be thanks to
the work that you and your team
has done so anybody listening to
this should be thankful of the
work that you and your team are
doing because it might help save
us from eight-hour flights across to
the US. Yeah,
we're just hoping, you know,
again, it's, it's important that
yeah, whatever we do, the public
buys into, you know, so getting
their opinion is what
Quesst is all about.
But we do, you know, for NASA,
you know, high-speed flight
is part of our,
kind of, the foundational
things that we're, we're working
towards.
Yeah.
Well, thank you again.
Really appreciate it.
It was great to talk to you.
And yeah, good luck for the rest
of the programme.
Pleasure talking to you, Neil.